refused to actually take a pin and
rotate that pin on a piece of cotton
around the position of Trump sir
then you're closer to the North Pole
than you art was though
the landscape of northern Norway is
pristine as beautiful is probably one of
my favorite places on the planet the
mountains bears so dramatic and they
come straight down to be to the beaches
on the edge of a sea the kayak is just a
perfect tool for exploring these fjords
and the interaction between you and the
whales is so unique when you're in a
kayak but you're close enough to
experience the energy of what's going on
pod of killer whales comes swimming past
you and they don't even turn sideways to
look at you because they're chasing the
Heron and the same with the humpbacks
you are a part of that food chain you're
experiencing it wider with very crux of
what's going on
never had a boring day paddling in
northern Norway the scenery is always
unfolding and it's always majestic in
this blender
Masami used to consider it or borealis
were their spiritual ancestors it puts a
whole mystical element into the north of
Scandinavia
but have boundless energy nothing about
one of the most fuel-efficient animals
on the planet but husky and that energy
is it crosses over to you when you're
caught up in the pack you feed off of
their energy and if you if you're quite
lazy by Nature they'll they'll vote
chivvy you along and I'll make sure that
you work work for your keep as well as
you know for supporting them it's a
unique way of travel you know it's going
much a way of traveling the northen but
in the highlands earth of snow and
mountain and it's absolutely beautiful
guiding people in this environment is
unique as much as being able to take
someone from a society that's wrapped up
for the majority of a year in cotton
wool and be able to remove that cotton
wool and take them out into the wild I'm
always looking for that wow factor that
expectation but around the corner is
going to be something that's going to
blow the minds away other people that
will travel in with you it is an amazing
honor and pleasure to be able to
experience that as a guide
you